this has to be one of the most requested
videos on the channel and today we're
starting the full Journey what's going
on guys my name's David Thomas I'm a
registered architect here in Western
Australia and today I'm taking you
through an entire archicad course 100
for free so over the next few weeks
every single Monday I'm gonna be
dropping one part at a time slowly
diving in deeper and deeper into our CAD
so that by the end of this course you're
going to be able to use arcad like a
complete expert if you get lost at any
point in time there are a series of
links down in the description below
including our 100 free Discord chat you
can join other professionals and
students alike simply try to better
themselves in the architecture
profession now enough of me let's get
started with part one of this completely
free arcad course okay welcome to your
very first archicad 26 tutorial and part
one of this completely free course now
today I'm a little bit under the weather
so I apologize if my voice is a little
bit nasally and a little bit sniffly but
we're going to try and get through this
in the best possible manner so whilst
you have arcad 26 open you'll see the
very basic view map and UI first of all
you're going to see a few markers in the
middle and you're going to see your
generic outline of all of your toolbars
and workspaces now I want to get you
familiar with what you're seeing right
here on the screen so let's take a deep
dive very quickly into the interface of
icad 26. first of all you're going to
have all of your elements up the top
including file edit new all of the
basics that you're most familiar with
you may or may not have CI tools and 4D
Library installed these two are
additional add-ons that I've personally
purchased and added on to make arcad a
little bit better we'll dive into all of
these a little bit later first of all
all you're going to really want to do is
tap on the window button come down to
toolbars and make sure you have the same
elements clicked as I do so we want
Australian drafting AIDS and we want
standard this will most likely say
International drafting aids for you not
Australian it just depends on what
template you have open and available
next you want to come across down to the
palettes section and make sure you have
these four selected at the same time we
also want to turn on Renovations and
Trace reference so I'll hit Renovations
come back up to window
palettes and also hit Trace reference
you'll see that Trace reference has
landed in the middle of our screen so
what we want to do is Click drag and
drop that into the palette on the right
hand side now we have our palette there
and we have our renovation layers at the
bottom to continue familiarizing
yourself on the left hand side you're
going to have this basic window and
Palette you can drag it further and
wider or you can simplify it by dragging
it shorter personally I like it in the
double format but you can have it
however you like so what we're going to
see on the left hand side is most of our
design and workflow tools so we're going
to have our walls our doors our Windows
our slabs and our objects as well so
this is the main palette you're going to
be using most of the time and if we
click on one of these elements you'll
see that the top toolbar completely
changes with all of the different
elements available to you for that
object I'll hit escape to exit out of
that menu so we can continue with the UI
down below you'll have a document
section which is a little bit more
Technical and we'll get into that later
but mainly here you have your grins you
have your text tools your line tools
polylines bubbles clouds and Camera
tools so these are more often
documenting as per the title and they're
not really used at the start until you
get a little bit deeper into arcad we
mainly focus on the design elements at
the top you're going to have your
windows up top as well so the more
actual Pages you open the more tabs you
can have at the top arcad is not like
Rhino it is not like Revit you can't
have multiple windows side by side so
even though if I try to click and drag
this 3D window it's not going to let me
actually open to side by side you can
only have one open at a time so on the
right hand side let's say I click on
this elevation you'll see it will open
up another Tab and we'll have the three
tabs open any one code you can keep as
many open here as you want it doesn't
really affect your performance too much
but if you have a large project I do
suggest keeping it pretty minimal and
closing those elements as you work
through now on the right hand side we
have basically our organizer and the
best way to work through archicad all
your layers all your maps all of your
different viewpoints including
elevations and sections
now what you'll see is at the top we
have four different icons we have our
main organizer which is our project map
we have our view map we have our layout
book and finally we have our publisher
sets all of these are quite Technical
and quite detailed so first of all your
project map is going to show you
everything and anything you could
possibly have in your project whilst
your viewmap on the other hand is going
to be defined exactly how you like it
and how you want it to be set out so for
instance you'll see that there's
different layers in the Australian
template including sketch design the
pages you would typically export for
sketch design for construction
development documents same sort of
system structural plans ceiling plans
all of the pages you would typically
have laid out now you can create new
folders on this side you can do whatever
it is you want on this side by simply
going down to the bottom and saving a
Viewpoint climbing folder or creating a
new folder in its entirety it really
depends how you want this structured and
set up but for a beginner it does not
matter too much because you're going to
format it in the layout book this is all
going to be here just to kind of make
your life a little bit more organized
and a little bit easier if you think
about Photoshop you can think about the
layers that's really what this is here
so speaking of layers archicad is a
layering system if you press command or
control L it will open up the model view
layers just like Photoshop you're going
to have millions and millions of layers
and you're going to be very careful when
adding new projects to layers themselves
so as you can see the template is quite
detailed and it has everything pretty
much broken down into every layer you
could possibly need beams exterior
General interior all very very generic
but enough for you to be able to
actually put the right things in the
right layer you'll see on the left hand
side we have all sorts of different
layer combinations which are basically
attached to your view map so if we close
that come back into our new map open up
any of these sketch plans we can right
click new settings on our out site plan
and you'll say that layer combination is
100 planned site so if I close that
command L again you'll see that if we
were to double click on the site plan it
would only show us these layer
combinations whereas if we change the
sketch it would show us a different
layer combination now this is critically
important when you're changing pages and
layouts so when you go from a site plan
to a floor plan to an elevation you
don't necessarily want to see all of
that information on site plans typically
you don't need to see the internal walls
on floor plans you definitely do so you
want to make sure that each layer
combination is perfectly set up for each
section in each page we can stick to the
defaults here just because it makes life
a hell of a lot easier and when you get
a bit more experienced you can tweak
this play with it update it change it so
for instance on the site plan if we
wanted to see the ceilings we could
press the little I button turn on
ceilings and then hit the update button
so that whenever we went back to the
site plan all ceilings were visible but
I don't want to do that so I'm just
going to click cancel and move out of
that space now focusing on this Central
UI in the middle which is our main
workspace and our main environment if
you zoom in a little bit using the mouse
scroll wheel you'll see we have two in
different markers here first of all we
have e01 and we have S01 by default e
will stand for elevation s will stand
for Section if you're completely new to
architecture an elevation is the
external of the wall it shows your
facade your architectural treatments it
doesn't go too much into the
construction details whereas a section
will actually cut through a building and
indicate what kind of construction
methodology of planning so is it a slab
on ground is it suspended Timber what
kind of roof structure Etc so both of
these serve different purposes your
elevation will talk about your
materiality your section will talk about
your constructability down the bottom we
have our toolbar that gets changed very
seldom one of the main things you might
change is your scale bar so in your
workspace here you in the model view you
will be working to a one-to-one scale
meaning if you measure one centimeter it
will be one centimeter but if you export
that page into a layout book it will
show it as a 1 to 100. if you want to
change that you just simply click on the
change scale and change it to whatever
scale you're looking for now if we come
into our view map across on the right
hand side and drop down to the ground
floor presentation plan you've seen some
things change the style and color
changes that's not too important at the
moment what is important is let's say
the scale is 1 to 200 and we wanted to
make it 1 to 100. we drew everything
updated it showed it exactly how we
needed to and then double clicked off
that page came back to it and realized
it was one to two hundred still in all
of our settings were messed up we simply
just need to drag it back to 1 to 100
zoom out a little bit so we can see
everything in that page come across the
settings here where you'll see the
little warning icon this warning icon is
telling you that the settings are not
saved and when you exit this page it
will revert back to default if you don't
want that to happen simply click on the
settings button go get current window
settings press OK and it will revert
everything to your current settings so
even if you simply zoom in it won't be
saved to that Viewpoint if I go back to
the first plan and the second plan it
will change it accordingly the last
thing you need to familiarize yourself
with in the UI is the actual layout book
and this is where we export to a PDF and
be able to actually present to people so
if we come across the layout book let's
just go to a100 ground floor plan you'll
see that our cat has a default layout
set up ready for you to go and utilize
as you see fit we'll go through how to
update this actual workbook and change
the title block and everything in
between in another part but for today
I'm just simply going through a generic
UI so as you can see by clicking on this
little section here it is showcasing the
ground floor at 1 to 100 scale if you
right click and select update it will
update that and show whatever is
available on the ground floor plan we
haven't drawn anything so it's still
blank and only showing our markers top
right hand corner we have a first
introduction of our schedules which is a
little bit more of a technical Advanced
feature we may or may not get into that
into this tutorial but it is a very nice
feature to have and something we can
detail later on down the track at the
bottom you'll also see this hashtag
signed with project name that is
basically telling you that this is an
automated feature same as drawn by same
as project ID and it will populate this
information automatically based on
information you provide so to change
that file info project info and you'll
see we have all of these project info
description boxes if we go project name
and title this free course press OK
you'll see the project name completely
changes so if we come back file info
project name we can continue to update
all of this information Nation one by
one and it will populate to the relevant
Fields now you don't have to populate
all of it you can only populate the
items that are actually required to you
so for instance if you only want to
document what's in the title block you
can update your project number Status
client client Zone win region site and
it will populate all of those things
down below if we don't want that free
course to be there again simply delete
it press OK it returns to project name
now that is the base introduction into
arcad 26 day one part one if you've
never used this product before there is
so much that can be done with this
program in such a short period of time
so for instance I could quickly draw a
shape going to 3D and my walls are
already done we'll begin modeling and
talking about how to actually create a
3D architectural Masterpiece in archicad
in part two anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching part one of this arcad course
if you enjoyed it make sure you hit that
subscribe button down below and turn on
the Note location Bell so you're
informed of when part two comes out next
week but like I said that is all for me
so I'll see you next Monday